welcome h3 army today we go to war with
facts knowledge logic no we don't know
those are there are allies in war those
are our allies yeah we go to war with
everything else
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh kaptara and honey i am joined
by the ever beautiful pregnant luscious
eel klein stand up ela Kleiner's you
don't really I mean metaphorically
speaking you can but they go let's see I
mean it is getting so crazy the the baby
bump because ILA's due June 6 and that
gives us basically almost a month I mean
we're almost a month away
oh the last month of our previous life
that's right it's gonna be just
different post Theodore work we did a
hospital tour recently and although it
was nice because the facility's nice I
was happy it was also terrifying because
they're like you could be spending three
days here yeah and I was like oh my god
I feel like sorry I feel like I'm to be
getting on a flight I got that feeling
like yeah I really enjoyed the part
where they said that if I'm gonna take
epidural you they're gonna let the
husband go for a walk because some
husbands have fainted before just from
looking yeah I was really quiet the
whole tour and then when she said that I
was verbal it was like oh my gosh but I
was like you know I'm gonna take the
walk doctor recommends a walk I don't
need to watch nothing because the
epidural is pretty insane that's the
painkiller that they they plug into your
spine yeah waiting so I do plan to take
if anyone is wondering let me tell you
right now I am taking it well they say
that will take your pain down from like
a nine or ten to a one or two yeah which
one or two um I can I think I can handle
you live consular with one or two just
by living with me
you know I mean their normal state of
being I
if I was you I would take the epidural
yeah plug me into the maker boy
and then because you're so dumb you
can't pee so that's put a catheter yeah
but she's like you can't but you're so
numb they don't even know what's going
on once you get plugged in you have to
lay on your side and you can't move
anymore yeah you could [ __ ] yourself
even in Delk just clean it up quietly
that is true you just show yourself
though it's all service baby you should
[ __ ] yourself you piss yourself all
good-bye my dream too bad we can't bring
shredder yeah but an you imagine
shredder in there oh my god no but it's
really nice it's getting very very real
the doors kicked right he's supposed to
move like ten times every hour because
you had said he wasn't moving much loud
not every hour but they say to watch for
at least ten movements in one hour and
they but he does more than that I had a
dream I had a such a vivid powerful
dream that Theodore was born and he had
Ella's eyes he had blue eyes and I said
in my dream I started like crying it was
crazy
so it was a good dream yeah
it was a great dream I was just so happy
he was so beautiful and he had your eyes
so I feel like he will have your eyes I
feel like you will have your eyes well
look like you it's gonna be a little you
I think it'll look like me with your
eyes because there's a 50/50 chance that
he's brown and blue yeah you can do
either your parents have blue eyes
mm-hmm so it's 50/50 his dad is very
proud to be a blue eyes not gonna be his
eyes they'll be your eyes she's always
like high-fiving me cuz we're in the
blue eyed class so he he goes as long as
the baby of blue eyes you sound like
you're Aryan bro
what do you end up with freaking not see
you Janet Jew Genesis
[Laughter]
today we were supposed to be joined by M
Chamberlin she is sick and couldn't make
it but was best wishes to her and God
bless yesterday we've got so much to get
to guys I mean come on you've seen the
title we got prank evasion we got it
we've got Kanye and Kim we've got DJ
Khaled is back but before that yesterday
I had a very important meeting I want to
talk to you guys about with two sweet
young men Ross and Jarrett now we had
joked recently or not recently but a
while ago about who would want to ever
make a wish for us you know as I met you
could see anybody you would you would
waste a wish on my look at my look at my
stupid face but so somehow we had it
where they both came in at the same
exact time because we've never done
make-a-wish before but these two guys
came in at the same exact time so we saw
them both on the same day but we were
there for like five hours so long there
and Ross and Jarrett these kids well
Ross this was Ross he's freaking awesome
dude why did it go what the hell how do
I scroll to the next picture I just push
to the right button it shows Jimmy
Kimmel yes
his mom was showing me that he throws up
the babe nation every photo he's just
like a hardcore ela kleiner showed up
his merch
it was just so sweet and humbling that
it's sometimes it's easy to forget cuz
me and he'll just sit in a room like
right now it's just me kneel in a room
and you can hear Dan laughing outside of
cages and which is nice mm-hmm but at
home we're sitting in a studio it's just
the two of us and you forget that
there's actually people watching him
that you actually yeah that you actually
do affect people's lives and I think for
it was probably was very important to me
it was very nice to get that a very very
nervous before I was nervous till it
feels so important
I was nervous I was nervous because it's
like dude this kid this is your wish I
mean yeah then you don't want to
disappoint they came out with their
whole family's on like a week-long trip
the whole purpose of that trip was to
meet and spend time with us crazy mm-hmm
but it is so humbling for that to
realize like the gravity of that
decision you know to meet us so I
thought it was a fantastic experience
they're both so awesome too
that's Ross the legend throwing it up
and that's jarett the legend under fupa
shot football day throwing it up all day
long
oh ice and then this is what the
make-a-wish have put together like an
itinerary we had to take a picture this
looks so official yeah I love that yeah
it was awesome and these guys roll and
yeah he just was great it was a totally
great experience so nice so nice of them
you know to come out spend their time
and and the make-a-wish Foundation these
people are incredible it's amazing what
the heck what how is their people so
nice and and generous and their hearts
are so full I mean to fly out a whole
family pay for everything everything
they go to Universal to and do like fun
stuff here oh paid for everything I
think we said they even gave them like a
thousand dollars right we're spending
bending so it's super easy for us we
just had to show up
it's unbelievable design was like these
people are so kind there's a whole
organization just to make these kids
wish come true I was like what I
wouldn't let my cold bitter heart would
never follow through on something that
beautiful you know what I mean it's
something I would daydream about but I
would never follow through him like you
have like daydreams you're like man I
wish somebody would try to
right now I'll be the hero or I wish
some would try to rob this cafe right
now I choke him out
save everybody you every call the guys
out there know what I'm talking about
right yeah you fantasize about like
someone robbing the restaurant and you
being the hero here at the office
actually I fantasize about it all day
someone breaking in and you being the
hero yeah yeah exactly and poor young
yoon-hee would ya what would he do
yeah Ian would be helpless and Dan would
say how do you feel about that Ian would
you be helpless in the event of a hostel
entrance yeah die instantly yes you
would just drop to the floor pretty much
just curl up butyl position and just
don't let it happen but have you
fantasized about that in I mean
seriously what would you do
do you think that you would rise to the
occasion or do you think Dan would take
care of the trash I mean it's so you
really have to experience it to see I
don't know
I don't know so let me paint a scenario
so you're in the kitchen someone comes
in with a gun he's got a gun pointed at
Han but he doesn't know you're there yet
so you have the opportunity to walk out
a kitchen and flank him from the side
but there's a chance you might turn to
meet you and your how do you handle that
situation do you cower in the kitchen or
do you attempt to disarm the guard the
gunman I'd attempt to I'd I'd grab the
hot coffee coffee good you've thought
about that don't actually give him sorry
for under us I mean Union was that off
the cuff or have you fantasized about
that that was off the cuff you told me
I'm in the kitchen I adapt I overcome
and Zach would you rise to the occasion
what do you think you do I mean you
wouldn't know to you get in that
situation but I'd probably go for a
knife or something like that you have a
knife on you no not on me but what the
hell you gonna do like what how you
gonna get enough if you're in the
kitchen there's just butter or do we
have steak knives I think you may just
have you may be limited a butter knife I
think we have a bread knife yeah you
know it's got that little serrated some
kind of just
like sharp object I guess yeah you would
be shot dead you would be shot dead
everyone be executed three months me one
time when I was younger I had a friend
over at my parents house but we were
alone afternoon like after school and it
was kind of a windy day and we were just
watching TV in the living room and all
of a sudden the front door just like
opened like super scary and and it just
stayed open I guess because of the wind
but we were like what the [ __ ] we
thought someone was there and we were
just wondering what do you do and I ran
and grabbed the the bread knife that's
why never mind like the big bread knife
oh so and so the bread knife in Israel
is actually scary no it's not is a it
has a rounded edge you'd have to like
saw him where they have did not yeah
well it's a serious one word it's long
and rounded at the end so you there's
literally no there's almost no but the
challah bread is pretty tough to get
through yeah so and we have stairs that
go like there's like a small stairway
that goes down to the front door and a
smaller one that goes up to the second
level so I had the knife and I was like
okay you you go up and watch the door
and I go down with the knife we had this
whole like how are we gonna do this
tactically ascertaining the city we were
terrified that's funny it's like a n and
we made it to the door and it was no one
there was the wind Wow when I was a kid
I used to I used to stay up horrified
every night cuz I was just obsessed over
enemy set and he sound I've ever heard
because I was always I don't know why I
was so obsessed that we were getting
broken into I was so afraid that our
house was broken into at night when we
were all there and I would only get to
sleep when like the Sun started to come
up and I was like no one's gonna break
in now hmm so my stuff but a couple of
nights I would hear someone like shuffle
like one of my family members shuffling
through the night and I didn't know
they're out and I was just like in my
mind I was like this is it
we're all gonna die so terrified yeah
but in my mind so now we're at home and
I'm an adult and anytime I fantasize
about this about what I would do I
always I I'm being realistic I cannot
stop an intruder that's why I bought a
gun because I cannot stop an intruder
well I've got a baseball bat I've got it
up fire escape ladder in my mind I lose
every time so that's why I bought a
freakin shotgun and I've got it ready
because that fantasy I always win or at
least I have a 50% chance of winning you
know what I mean that's why I got to be
real dude I'm not I'm not the hero that
thinks he is do you come up with any
like catchphrases and you're like
fantasy like go in that event like
Arnold no I'm scared and I'm shooting
and I'm praying to die like it get to
the chopper I should think of something
they'll get slammed Barry ooh
his name's Barry gets slammed Barry yeah
I like owning a gun it makes me feel
very safe but I own so actually I was
very when I was shopping around for a
gun for home defense no other purpose
for it it was recommended to me to get a
shotgun which surprised me a lot I was
thinking that you would want to get a
handgun or something but apparently
handguns are more dangerous because it's
one singular shot that's more powerful
that can go through walls and
potentially hit your neighbors or or
other people in other rooms where the
shotgun is you know it sprays and it's
harder to miss and it does not go
through walls
so for home defense the shotgun is
definitely mm-hmm it's definitely
superior and I got like a I got a seven
shot semi-automatic baby
yeah so even so so even you know with my
experience with my experience I have a
pretty good chance of taking out even
John wicks if he comes into my house I
have a 25% chance that's it and I have
defensible high ground too
hmm I made sure we had that when we
found a new house so guys I have
fantasized about this at great length
and I always lose that's the problem we
have a new video on h3 h3 about Kim and
Kanye and their new sinks if you guys
haven't watched it it's up there
apologies to Ian
um I know Ian is a super Kanye fan I
warned him before Kim are you a super
Kim fan in or I mean it's mostly Kanye
and because he's married to Kim
therefore you're a fan of Kim yeah yeah
exactly I am are where you petrified Ian
I mean be honest when you saw her new
video well you made it out lights I
always think if you want your kids to
old and disgusted or had it wasn't that
bad yeah wasn't that bad I was just
afraid of what you may you know say and
you're a little unhinged you're a little
crazy so I wasn't sure what effect
here's this here's this the part about
their sink that your kids to know I want
my kids to be kind the water go the
water look at this sink there's no hole
there okay well well so Kim goes on to
explain like it's hard to see that
there's a hole here apparently this was
the hole but so here I was like well
there's no hole here there is a hole
here but it looked like it was just like
part of the water are well but so so
here's Kim this is kind of an update a
follow up to our video explaining how
her sinks work so I thought this was
pretty interesting your okay so since
everyone is a little bit confused about
our sinks I thought I would just show
you guys a little tour of our bathroom
that's our patio out there our whole
ceiling is a light box bathtub it's all
of our cake
our whole ceiling is a light box the
bathtub is card from Jade wait the back
that's the patio
yeah it doesn't turn
very spacious for pet it doesn't look
very private for a bathroom well that's
just that's a great point and probably
there's nobody it's not a nobody
yeah there's nobody there Jesus nobody
goes wandering around it yeah what the
hell gardener
the roof is edges yeah get a hole well
it's nothing we haven't already seen
right in and be honest you've watched
the Kim Kardashian sex tape wait what
sorry you've watched the Kim Kardashian
sex tape right no I've never was okay in
so lame because he's so deep into the
Kanye community that he's afraid to
admit to anything there could be you
know potentially compromising to the
community that's not watching and now
aware of his existence so anytime I
asked him a question he's just take
bleeds the fifth and it's so lame I know
you beat off to that sex tape Ian why
would you and all of them have
rightfully I mean it's her claim to fame
correct me if I'm wrong
I haven't beat off to it it's not I mean
I've seen it it's not good okay maybe I
haven't beat off all it but you've
watched it as you everyone have sinned
it in must have sinned it eally have you
seen it I don't know I may have actually
you've seen it was like before I was
aware of came in Konya and the whole Ian
please just admit to me tell me you
could you don't have to tell me what you
think but at least tell me that you've
seen it so I know you're not full of
crap I have seen thank you wow dude
that's super disrespectful account no
Kanye says that he used to beat off to
it in that video that boat video
he knew Kim was the one when he saw her
in a paparazzi pic wait Paris oh yeah
with Paris Hilton that's okay to Konya
doesn't give a single Frick he's such a
troll in that video so at any rate
there's a couple of dudes in that Bush
beating off right now probably oh
[Laughter]
ceiling is a light box
bathtub it's all of our kids the bathtub
is made from the ivory of a thousand
elephants and shower so okay so this
thing's con me through this
Kanye Axl vibora and clapping she says
don't knock Axl before I mean it's not
that crazy
like Kanye drew this Axl of or dreamed
it up and no actual vort once time hit
his head and trimmed it up when it was
passed out in the hospital trunk that
redid this sink and Claudia was the one
that should be separated from the wall
cause he wrote it up against the wall
but we thought it would be cooler this
way so so let me get this straight but
you use you don't actually walk back
there because the waters rising not
anymore
an axial octavo vault did agree with her
now what she said it used to be against
this the wall and then they moved back
which means they tore it out and read it
right and then moved in that could have
been better they got to make the sink
like 360 so you can use the water from
the other side it's already gonna be
mm-hmm
approachable from that side mm-hmm Ian's
comment because he didn't hear you but
it does actually like slightly sloped on
that you can kind of see and there's a
slit for the water
you can honors high pressures you want
and no backsplash will come up see I
don't I don't buy that
yeah I'm fine totally get back you
something else so oh yeah
I don't bind the whole room wait it one
time I think I missed it but she says
there was like eight iterations of it
hello let me go back cuz yeah sorry
I know Axl before we gotta get a
somebody for saying Axl ofwar sorry I
won't pause anymore sync and claudia was
the one that should be separated from
the wall because i used to be against
the wall big Axl was okay with Nicola
this audio Phone 8 version prototypes
sync was made eight versions it's not
that serious erecting slits in it
apparently their house cost seventy
million now I know why I spent 10
million just trying to Maxwell board and
Claudia going back and forth on the
slits and the distance from the wall so
you telling me anyone is using this room
cuz there's no like toothbrush there's
no towel that's a great point there's no
evidence of anyone living there Ian I
don't know heard their toothbrushes
she's right she's got a point there's no
evidence of anyone living there I
thought you were a superfan so Kim and
Kanye don't brush their teeth man they
don't believe in a toothbrush there's
people that have fluoride conspiracies
did you know that they think fluoride is
a mind control and there's fluoride in
their water
yeah this Floyd in the water so don't
drink tap water yeah maybe that's them
yeah they're light switches are not good
by the way yeah it looks just like
unfinished like cable wires and they go
on dim
and off and there's no box I'm sorry but
this is such a try-hard house and
there's no box around it okay I'm all
for like cool designed houses but this
is just trihard absolutely
three buttons and also they look like
steampunk they look like old operator
buttons from like the nineteen like 50s
it doesn't look nice
three little nubs I don't like the nubs
and also why are they you know if you've
got the whole white pure thing what was
Dan steel like brass I don't think it
fits I don't know what axle will work
thinks about it but I don't think it
fits Ian what do you think about the
buttons if they're axial I like it I
have a feeling that maybe audio anyway I
think their house is annoying
I think if axle maybe it would be like
three rocks yeah three second girl would
be three stones I'm over it
oh yeah and then there was a kind of a
follow-up Kardashian story that I
thought was funny now Ian you show this
to me whose birthday was this from
Kourtney Kardashian yesterday and on
their napkins it says Kim there are
people that are dying now is there
context to this Ian that I'm unaware of
no I don't I don't know what's up with
this Tim there are people that are dying
and like printed on the napkin so I
think there were multiple quotes from
different family members but I don't
that's a weird thing to put on a napkin
I don't know okay so they were honoring
each other by putting quotes all over
the place I mean I think so because I
saw a different napkin that said
something else hmm I guess it's funny
they probably took late stupid
statements that from the show they've
made yeah okay yeah with the napkin yeah
I'm not American doesn't bother me as
much as the father sink and the buttons
on the wall should get those buttons to
yourself Kim
I'm gonna cry Mac we should call up Axl
oveur I wonder what can we have him do I
want to have him design like a mega vape
for me you know what I mean mm-hmm I'll
be sick
all right well enough BS let's get to
the show at hand
prank invasion has gone worldwide his
incest prank was was was received by
everyone now by the way he he doesn't
give me credit I'm pretty sure that
story broke after we mention it in our
video cuz we had a tweet exchange yeah
yeah I'm sorry I don't happening only
after I I think that we can take full
credit as always for his exposure in his
success hmm so prank invasion came at me
recently or over the past week on
Twitter talking mad [ __ ] and I had to
dunk on him hard
hard and furious and fast because you
got to keep that stuff you gotta you got
to control the narrative before it gets
out of control because he started
challenging me to chess matches he went
also flow on me it's like come up with
your own ideas why are you still from
Soflo he challenged me to a chess match
for a hundred thousand dollars I was
like that is very so flowing of you
well anyway we've got a ton of articles
of all these people covering it we've
got these tweets we've got the beef all
laid out like Thanksgiving dinner for
who eats what did you eat beef on Easter
dinner Christmas dinner I played no need
to be we got the ham all spread out but
we got to take a quick commercial break
when we come back there's so much to
talk about let's get it on baby hello
fresh is a meal kit delivery service
that shops plans and deliver
step-by-step recipes and pre-measured
ingredients so you can just cook eat and
enjoy how the fresh does all the meal
planning shopping and prepping so you
can focus on a healthier you and a
happier well-fed beautiful family fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
easy-to-follow six step picture dress
the cards are delivered to your door
each week and a special insulated box
that is beautiful you get this beautiful
box with like an ice pack in it
it is not gonna go bad folks that's my
guarantee to you three plans to choose
from classic veggie and family with the
option to switch between them when your
tastes change you know what I love about
it too is it gets you out of that rut
because sometimes you get stuck eating
the same thing over and over and over
and you don't know what to cook they're
gonna spice it up they're gonna send you
all kinds of different things to get you
out of your comfort zone discovering new
delicious recipes I love this hello
fresh and I'll tell you it's so fun yes
I sometimes I want to cook but I want to
go to the grocery store I don't want to
look up a recipe and I don't know what
to make so they take all the tedious
crap out of it and what you're left is
just the fun part they send you all the
ingredients all packaged up beautiful
meat beautiful recipe you cook it up by
the bing bada boom you've got a
delicious meal with all the hassle
forget about it huh my favorite dish was
the sesame beef tacos Oh mmm so good so
bomb ah
and we've got a special offer for you
$80 off your first month of hellofresh
if you go to hellofresh calm slash
pastry podcast 80 and enter the code h3
podcast 80 that's go to hello fresh comm
slash issue podcast 80 and enter the
code h3 podcast 80 you that's like
receiving eight meals for free that's
ample opportunity to give it a shot
you're gonna fall in love with it I
guarantee it it's fresh beautiful
healthy come on forget about it huh
we've all read some surprising online
reviews right whether you're trying to
get a sweet deal on something you've
been saving for are you trying to find
the best happy hour in town it's
generally a good idea to read the
reviews first so why should finding the
right software for your business be any
different read thousands of real
software reviews and find the right
software for your business at kaptara
comm / h3 kaptara is the leading free
online sword resource to help you find
the best software solution for your
business with over 750 thousand reviews
of products from real software users
discover everything you need to make an
informed decision search from more than
700 specific categories of software
everything from project management to
email marketing to yoga studio
management software that is niche as it
gets no matter what kind of software
your business needs kaptara makes it
easy to discover the right solution a
fast joy the millions of people use
kaptara each month to find the right
tools for their business
now we've you've kaptara recently we're
looking for accounting software just
something to help on a personal level to
help you know keep track of our itemized
deductions because it's such a pain in
the ass like putting it in Excel but
that's the beautiful thing whatever you
need they've got the best software
they've got the reviews you're gonna be
shocked by how helpful this website is
so visit kaptara COMSOL sh3 for free to
date to find the tools to make an
informed software decision for your
business kappa terre des hommes / h3
that's kaptara capt e RR a.com slash h3
kaptara software selections simplified
you know what rhymes with honey ela free
money that's right you ever buy
something online only find out later you
missed a discount yes it has happened to
me and I have not let the anger go from
it that is the worst feeling in the
world
but you don't have to experience that
anymore because I don't overspend
anymore thanks to honey honey is a free
browser add-on that finds me the best
deals online that magically Auto applies
the best deal to my cart at checkout
honey finds discounts and coupons across
37,000 websites
Amazon Sephora Best Buy Nordstrom's and
more they've got all of them
with honey I don't even worry about
missing a deal I just shop like normal
and hoodie handles the rest look over
here on this coupon we at recently
bought some outdoor furniture all of a
sudden Bob's your uncle shopping like
normal at the checkout boo twenty bucks
saving that I wouldn't have saved
otherwise because I don't spend 30
minutes scouring the internet for
coupons like a lunatic honey saves you
the time and effort you don't have to be
that neurotic anymore honey has saved
it's 10 million members an average of
twenty eight dollars honey members have
already saved more than eight hundred
million dollars not bad for something
that's completely free and takes just
two clicks to install honey is over a
hundred thousand five star reviews on
Google Chrome store and Time magazine
calls honey basically free money look
there's really no reason not to try
honey it's free to use it's easy to
install it just takes two clicks people
let's shop with confidence let's get
honey for Christ's sake
honey is free go to join honeycomb slash
a tree that's join honey calm
/h Street it's gonna change the game up
for you save that money save that time
eat that honey let's go boy
brotherly love youtuber reveals it was
it really was his sister he snogged and
prank video and fans are horrified now
by the way every time that one of these
articles tries to be like prank invasion
confirms it was his sister it's just
them going so was it your sister and
he's like yeah that's it doesn't prove
anything you know why because in their
minds since they're not familiar with
him they go why would anyone lie making
out with their own sister but what we
know about Chris is that that exactly he
would lie about you know there's 0%
chance that's his sister like if you go
back in time and all their social medias
there's no mention even of any of them
before and all of a sudden it's like hey
it's my sister and from out of town that
really and apparently she's got pictures
of him in her room come on sorry
who has that's so creepy why would
anyone have a picture of like their
brother and and when they live at the
same house at this age - it's not like
Oh a picture of us his kids yeah this
was posted the day before by the way the
prank so nice investigating the son
that's a tablet right yeah so but they
did a hole right up man and I loved I
love this picture of Chris he's so
bronzed really thank you in the 90s I
think is missing his frosted tips and I
would definitely I would definitely go
elbow deep in his ass if you have
frosted tips so there you have it
there's so many articles like this the
son there's some really funny ones the
Univision which is American
spanish-language this is a big this is a
big show right Univision look at this I
don't know why they got it looking like
Chris is popping a pimple on the floor
Bessel's ah su hermana and boco como
blow ma para
so Brenda a sous say Gwen Doris
native-speaker man sure yeah could you
tell sin royal uh there you have it
prank evasion around the world this one
is great you read it so bad I figure I
could wear that you want to give it a
shot go ahead what the hell do I know
just phonetically go ahead go ahead
but vessel is su hermana and boca como
broma I don't think it's better maybe it
says bad well I don't think that your
net use you didn't like come out with
this beautiful Spanish no I'm not gonna
try to well you have to read it like a
football announcer Bessel's ah su
hermana and Boca whoa no got roll the
arse a little more mana for my 9 la boca
yeah there you go
that sounds racist calm down exactly
that's a mana this one's great the Daily
Mail snapchat story this is a fantastic
headline you guys will love this
incest alert sound the bell I love that
there's an alert for it and says alert
YouTube prankster horrifies fans by
passionately kissing his sister for
video yes sir
incest alert I love that rat sound the
alarms what's not excited there's been
these DMS floating around I'm not gonna
show it because who knows but apparently
he's been approaching people to shoot
pornography there's these DMS going
around it he offered some girl five
thousand dollars to shoot a porn which
is not that I mean he basically does
already shoot porn so it doesn't shock
me hmm
but where's he going where's he posting
his porn to cuz that's the question
right cuz as far as I'm aware I haven't
seen any pornography maybe but maybe
it's the hot new thing maybe it's just
some bro pranking me just started
pornhub channel that be sick that's
probably common why why is it not coming
literally you God uh can you imagine
[Music]
[Laughter]
Holly there was another prankster that
did end up going the porn route
well Vitaly was in a horn before his
prank days and he couldn't get it
famously he could not get it a ride yeah
it was great he was did a bang bang bus
with his one of his buddies and his
buddies who got hard and was able to
perform and Vitaly was just there stuck
jerking off his limp [ __ ] in the corner
of the bus yeah it's pretty good pretty
great it's pretty wild I mean if you're
gonna bro if you're gonna go on a bang
bus you better be able to get it up but
I just love that he went on to you know
prank fame and now there's a picture of
him jerking off his limp dick yeah it's
a good watch so this one gets good he
tweeted at me unprovoked um last week
let me go back here first he says hey
h3h3 productions you declined a boxing
match with me fair enough
you're not stupid how about a chess
match for $100,000 you're much smarter
so it should be easy money right where'd
you go to college again [ __ ] idiot so
first of all he's I guess I don't know
before I break this down I don't know
how serious he is our how much she's
trolling it's hard to tell but like we
had spoken with him previously we had
tried to get him on the show and he was
very strange and very not self-aware and
not he was very unsound
let's put it that way and so I part of
me thinks that he is for real yeah I
think even even if he's like trying to
be funny or whatever I think the essence
is still him being real yeah I think he
thinks that him being good at chess is
evidence so we're like where did you go
to college again like he's actually
trying to make fun of where
you want to call it yeah yes yes yes yes
yes definitely so there's a couple
assertions here one being that if you're
smart you're inherently good at chess
like you don't need to practice you
don't need to know anything about it
you're just inherently good and then too
I guess
College makes going to a good college
means you're smart so somebody said you
need to go to college to be smart and he
said this is the best in my opinion he
goes reread my statement your reply is a
logical fail I would know because I
scored a 174 on the L ast L ast which
got me into northwestern law after
graduating with top honors from UC
Berkeley by the way the L SAT is an exam
and logic that's like straight out of
time fourteen this deep so again when I
read that I was like man is this guy for
real
you know yes thank you a year of Maya is
a logical fail it's hard to use the word
logical not sound like a like in the
context so anyway he said so to his
initial offer a challenge I said this I
challenge you to an SD STD test that
went over great on Twitter actually as
alright believable I like cried like I
was getting like text and DM from people
being like man that was a great tweet
yeah thank you
Gould almost 140,000 likes on that saw
was I was feeling very very precious on
that day I remember when you first told
to me before you tweeted it she laughed
out loud it was a real life which is
rare I was like oh [ __ ] I was like ela
I'm thinking about writing I detest and
she laughed out loud I was like oh good
first about a lot of tweets and the
tough cookies sometimes I'll just stare
at him he's no smiley this is how I know
it's bad I give I pitched something and
she goes
tough crowd she's a tough crowd
so got lots of kudos there and then it
Chris kind of devolved into the madness
as usual and I quote tweeted his
response about logical fail I said since
you were studying to be a lawyer maybe
you can tell me the laws regarding
boning your sister it is illegal by the
way you know what I learned kind of
interesting it's illegal to have sex
with your sister
but it's not illegal to have sex with
your brother if you're a guy so because
I guess when they wrote this law in like
1800 whoever they didn't even it was too
monstrous to imagine a brother sleeping
with her brother mm-hmm that blessed
that's blossom that's like nuclear
blasphemy so so technically speaking it
is legal if you are brothers to have sex
or sisters
you just can't cross you can't breed I
guess that's the good part
you don't want that baby in the world
you don't want in suspect shout out to
my brother Shawn no but Chris Chris was
melting down on Twitter he had a lot of
he started going here I'll show you the
rest of his tweets he started going on
and on about like thanks for the
exposure I had a brand deal but they
said my Twitter engagement was too low
and now I got the brand I'm like shut up
that's how Brad deals work like oh come
on it's not letting me look at his
tweets because it's not here it is
thanks invaders my brand deal confirmed
a nice bonus due to these awesome
Twitter stats by the way it has 38 likes
awesome engagement bro nice bonus do
these awesome Twitter stats and I've
never even promoted my Twitter from
YouTube once damn he got you he got you
so good he goes he's not owned
he goes you see that magic the brand dia
wanted to pay me 25,000 but they said my
Twitter impressions were low compared to
my YouTube Instagram boom I engineered
this and played you fools daddy got his
check now 80 likes engineered us bro
that is not how brand deals work and
then his latest tweet 21 likes so that's
he's kind of he's his normal engagement
was like six likes before all this
happened so I'm sure that his brand deal
who's gonna pay him twenty five thousand
is like all right dude
you finally got enough Twitter
impressions this is a go we're green
lighting this yeah this got really go to
law school you're [ __ ] kidding me I
don't think so he said thank you that's
you said he got into law school but he
preferred alternative career path
engineered life yeah he's great he
scares me a little bit I made it you mad
no man I love it he keeps saying [ __ ] to
me like beat me in a box mess or chess
mess I'll give you a hundred thousand
dollars and delete my channel it's like
bro how many times you ever say I do not
want you to delete your channel that's
the last thing I want you to do I want
you to keep doing your thing as usual
and keep getting that beautiful tan
that's nearly black place to be honest
yeah love them congratulations Chris and
all your exposure and on the brand deal
I'm happy we could help you out how's
your chess game anything bad I don't
know how to play chess you're smart
right you're smart right so you could
beat me at chess no do you know watch
Rico Morty mm-hmm
I do what that's a fair point I have
watched every episode of Rick amore that
is all the training I need what's
something I could be Chris a beak prank
evasion in
views popularity Zaku dignity dignity
yeah probably
well yeah probably dignity and and and
and I don't I'm not saying I have much
of it but I think even Bill Cosby at
this point has more dignity than men
prank invasion I think prank evasion
went 4-0 dignity when he did mommy make
out they I wonder if all these new
stories that were like he he he verified
it's his sister I've seen mommy make out
there you know I bet that they did not
yeah there's also pregnant they know
what was it oh yeah pregnancy days are
absolute lie I mean come on mmm kissing
pranks gay addition gay this fantastic
[Music]
so they're there
the beef is fresh its new Chris I love
you I welcome you back to the fray keep
making them keep pushing it he always
finds new territory which I'm excited
about incest what's next just straight a
pedo addition that would be that would
be the next level we're making out with
my 12 year old cousin you know he did
high school addition he did one of my
favorite videos of yours ever on that's
right yeah yeah closer look I think he
needs to lower the age he needs to go
middle school edition yeah gotta push
the boundaries I mean what else could he
do at this point the top incest edition
mom edition Zach says newborn edition
elderly elderly would be good and not
legal or not illegal elderly would be
dope but I don't want to cuz he's done
milfs I don't want seem else I want you
like now like 70 what's the problem with
that is that I don't think anyone wants
to watch that like all these little kids
be there me don't do not want to watch
that maybe small very small I'm sure we
already hired a cougar champ there is a
demo for it
yeah I want to see a kid edition
convalescent home edition like in a in a
hospice would be next level funeral
edition in front of a final case edition
last kiss Edition god how do you top it
corpse Edition corpse Edition I want it
probably has a list like that yeah we're
doing now spits all day doing his life
like what do you call this place where
they keep corpses more more MORE
Morgenstern mortuary edition now where
they keep them in the freezer all right
yeah work yeah morgue edition I want him
to share that dock with us mmm how much
would you pay for that hundred thousand
I'm hurtin to delete his channel and
I'll become the new prank invasion that
documents blank by the way I don't think
there's much going on in that document
so something interesting happened ela
said she saw a picture of Ben Affleck's
back tattoo you showed me I showed it to
her because I was like what I was like
man you guys see this Ben Affleck has
this huge crazy back tattoo of I guess
it's like a phoenix I don't really know
but it's huge it curves its whole
freakin back super colorful it's it's
well done for what it is but it's like
you just you would never expect it so
and ela told me I'm shocked I can't
believe this is real it's real baby I
think this is the worst tattoo I have
ever seen and I'm in it she said really
a minute
well she said Ethan I think this may be
the worst tattoo I've ever seen
now I feel like that can't be true can
it why do you hate it so much it's just
awful I like where do I begin I don't
know the character like ways that the
call
these Phoenix the fact but it's all over
his back right it's the size that
bothers you it's the color it's the it's
just way too much it's like if I had to
put a visual next to the word awful
mm-hmm Wow well I trust ela she knows
what she's talking about
but what the thought I had was like well
hold on I bet you I can find worse
tattoos so we put together segments here
of bad tattoos we have celebrities and
general bad ones alike and ela is gonna
ask us here and tell us is it worse than
Ben Affleck's back tattoo so I'm gonna
put this one right here and I'm gonna
open up the new ones and we'll look at
him side by side
I wonder what age did he get it I think
it was a midlife crisis thing like
something you would get at 18 and then
no he got quit it
no he got it when he was already like
mature I think he maybe you can look
that up you guys I that is a good
question but I pretty sure was a midlife
crisis move so here we go Ed Sheeran's
chest tattoo now when I saw this eel I
think you might have a run for your
money here I think this one's worse I
actually do and you tell me what you
think oh my god so so ed sherene has a
huge alliance while I agreed this is so
bad I still think Ben Affleck is worth
really I feel like the art on this one
is worse like it kind of it's like a
down downy lion also what's with the
purple I always feel like this is ironic
though it's you do Brody you don't do
you really
you put a huge lion on your chest
ironically it's like where you have your
head chest hair it's always funny
oh I didn't thought about that why is
all this chest hair purple and yeah it's
probably from the process of making he
probably had to bail cuz doing the chest
area is really painful to get tattooed
oh look he's got a teddy bear on his own
I see that that's cool so hilo likes
this one better and I still don't like
it but it's not as yeah okay hey I have
a pretty funny update on this and a half
like that dude so okay apparently it was
seen publicly for the first time in 2015
and he was asked about an interview and
he said it was fake for a movie he
denied that it was real and then that
picture is from late last year it's real
that it's real so I think he's aware
that it's bad lately he was denying that
it was tattoo
yeah yeah and more recently he lied
about it I love that how does that make
it worse break it down
shame about it publicly he lied Wow but
it's a real what what year did you say
well it was first seen in 2015 according
to this article 2015 in so what age was
he then in 2015 uh let's see that's what
four years ago yep he's currently 46 so
42
yeah I mean that's been life crisis he's
got ten years on me can you imagine me
showing up one day with that no well
that's what he did okay so I present to
you now II look for your consideration
Chris Brown's tattoo of Rihanna on his
neck now one thing I mean I can already
tell you're not as mad
okay well why does she it's weird cuz it
looks like she has a black eye hi where
is it yes no it's literally the shot
from when he beat her up he got a
tattooed on his neck no yeah no you say
no cause it's just so insane yes that is
the case are you serious no I don't
believe that that's not true oh my god
you I don't believe that you have to
prove that
what that's humbly no there's that's not
possible then you're saying he got the
mug shot of Rihanna all beat up that he
did to her tattoo on his neck are you
[ __ ] with me I mean that's my
understanding of the situation that's
not true that can't be true well I mean
no one let's go I'm looking it up right
now to confirm but that that is the
impression that I got dude there's no
there's absolutely no way that's true I
will I will die if that's true right now
on the spot
well buildings about to collapse so it
looks like he's denied it but I mean we
probably don't want to show the picture
of her on the podcast but you do a
comparison back yeah yeah I mean pretty
similar what um how can that be true I
guess they are
I think he's representative said that
it's a tattoo of a sugar call something
completely unlike a Mexican a Mexican
celebration of the Day of the Dead
really you look at a comparison of the
it's hard to tell
it's not a very photorealistic tattoo
but the resemblance is certainly there I
mean a the Mexican elements don't like
on them those things the stitches yeah
but it looks like a girl with a black
eye was there was her mouth busted up
Dan uh yeah yeah her lips are cracked
I'm looking at the photo right now it's
[ __ ] up yeah it is it's rough to look
at that yeah um that if that I mean
that's I mean that's like
it's like oh it's I don't know I mean I
even know what to say about that like
people are still I'm flabbergasted I'm
speechless that I refute I can't but
again he's putting I mean this woman has
a cracked lip in a black eye so and he
did that famously to another woman yeah
though I mean I I do recognize the
resemblance to the Day of the Dead yeah
it's as if it were like a two-faced kind
of thing like one half is that and one
half is not but at the same time you got
to be a little sensitive yeah when
you're when you're almost most famous
for being [ __ ] out of this woman maybe
not get a woman with the black guy in
the neck
I think it's not her if you ask me it's
veteran I feel like that's I mean I mean
dude if he goes out there and tattoos
Rihanna beat up on his neck who I would
you see that's like how does he go on
with his life like I know
yeah there's no way right no okay so
you're rating on this one not as bad
yeah no that's bad I'm with you
it was interesting though none though so
this one uh this one's pretty bad lena
Dunham's weird-ass cheeto Odeon tattoo
now Dan what is the background this
because I didn't even understand what I
was looking at as I pulled out the
background is that it's a restaurant in
New York that she's a big fan of and
they have like kind of a orange neon
sign why does it look like it's raised
not as been already time it looks like
puffy Cheetos why is it look raised what
it's not right and it's probably just
because right afterwards I think it's
fresh yeah hell and that Mercer must be
bomb we gotta go to the Odeon to go to
the Odeon okay yeah I I was pretty
surprised I was like well okay awful
Mark Wahlberg's shoulder tattoo he
recently got one of them professionally
removed
yeah Walbert Oh what am I even looking
at here
nobody was film Wahlberg oh wow
mark wall guys initials is that his
birthday or is that yeah I think so what
a dumbass he got his birthday and his
initials and his name
wait are we sure maybe like is I someone
with died in his family
well that so Dan don't they get the
right because I'm gonna look like an
[ __ ] if that's true yeah what's his
birthday 1971 June that's his birthday
thank God
yeah that's [ __ ] why don't you just
at that point tattoo your ID your
driver's license so not as mad I was bad
thoughts Chris is I tell us funny okay I
don't know you too much I don't know
it's like the idea was to be ironic with
this well he's having them
professionally removed but I'm giving
people the benefit of the doubt except
Ben cuz that one cannot be ironic even
he said that right right right there's
no room for doubt okay so Ben still is
the the winner here not it we're moving
all of you I meant it when I saw it I
believe you so we're moving on from the
celebs now going to general bad so we've
entered the general population because
you said worst of all time and I'm
holding you to that
okay so let's move on to this ocarina of
time tattoo okay here it's a Nintendo 64
controller with the nipple as the d-pad
go the analog the other analog stick
thoughts feel oh nice man really I like
how the cable is going into his skin
like it's plugged directly into his
heart just play with his nipples what
he's saying I think is the message he
loves nipple play not as bad it's it's
again it's ironic it is come on
okay alright I hear you and it's not
like I also just think this one is so
ugly like I'm I hear you that previous
one you just showed not as a great me at
least I'm right there with you I'm only
here to prod your brain and get your
thoughts next we have a rip MJ tattoo so
here we go
rest in peace to Michael Jackson 1958 to
2008 he was stopping the show to take a
picture of show horse rider is sleeping
so this one is up there so what we have
is a portrait of a woman that like a bra
I think it's a Brian what we've got here
is a rest
rest in peace with a portrait of Michael
Jackson that it looks like it was drip
Retton humming drum Drent drawn by a 5th
grader
yeah we're truly awful truly truly awful
they hear that being said I can still
tell it's Michael Jackson that's true so
that's a tough one I would still I put
the second the thing is because come on
because Ben is Ben it makes his much
their whole package yeah you have to
take a whole package yeah yeah okay this
is number two well we got close and this
is just the first of the plebs so or the
second now this one Neela you're gonna
be I feel like you're gonna be
challenged here alright this one's
called the cow hole and I think it's a
cow and a huge hole on his on his belly
button that looks like a giant gaping
cow [ __ ] I have no idea why anyone
would think not to this on themselves I
mean I guess they think it's funny
and there's flies going around it
yeah yeah awful yeah it's ironic already
though it is but here the problem is
that it's so not funny that and he
thought it was funny yeah he thinks I
have a problem there the tattoo itself
is good great
no the lights are good no no huh I don't
know no you got to place it here
let me hit you with the tension music is
it 1 2 or 3 the cow hole Ben Affleck cow
hole
or rest in peace Michael Jackson I think
this one goes number two now
okay so Benz I thought about it a lot
it's a tough one
yeah I don't know I mean if you saw
someone shirtless with this verse what
Ben has well again it's Ben you have to
consider that it is Ben Affleck yeah not
just some random bro this is Batman
we're talking about who is this he's a
fart the guy probably you know has a
farm literally right so I get I see what
you're saying and she's you are putting
a lot of thought to this so people at
home who are who are in disbelief ela is
thinking very strongly about this and
finally our final entry is Marilyn
Monroe portrait so here we go Aaron
Monroe adorned by roses and smile after
she was beat up by Chris Brown it looks
like she had a face transplant oh my god
alright with that tension music it's not
up there the toughest one was become
definitely the calm and really really
hates that tattoo well guys if you have
any other tattoos to stream a you're
like Ben Affleck is like you know
probably so many girls look up to him
these two two alone make him undatable I
think most girls would think it's cool
no I don't think so
I have to think that the answer is no I
think most girls would look past that
I'm saying you're not most girls I'm not
saying I disagree because you are
different than most girls you look but I
think many girls would still squirt all
over him at the first chance they got
including myself
I was back if you saw Scarlett Johansson
and she had this tattoo on her back I
heard guys are not the same guys we'll
look through everything no but I I'm
Kate
yeah I'm capable of seeing where you're
coming from I mean it means a lot like
about his personality too he is pretty
crazy I could this makes me think that
is nuts
he is nuts unstable he is he is I mean
he yes he is
that's what I think too you know they
say you women who are crazy have the
best sex I don't know that that
translates to men you know what I mean I
say women are crazy [ __ ] the best I
don't think that's true like Ben Affleck
like with this tattoo like what kind of
kinky [ __ ] does he do when when someone
like this you end up like our Kelly yeah
that's what I think that's what happened
because I know he's a drinker and so I
think you get a black robe yeah a sex
cult and they gotta call you daddy
yeah crazy doesn't work the same way
with men it's just scary yeah alright
well there you have it
congratulations you love and we'll give
it to that cow so - I'm still I'm gonna
lose sleep tonight on if I made the
right call to show and do some thinking
meanwhile everybody if you have some
great tattoos you want to submit to us
podcast a h3 reproductions calm I love
to see your entries I want this to be
ongoing because Allah she's got her work
cut out for her here and I think that
there's a lot of there's a lot of
thoughts and a lot of possibilities out
there we have a picture of shredder that
you want it was desperate just for to
share open original here it is alright
congratulations EULA it was fantastic
thank you we got to get more segments I
wonder if people agree with me I don't
think so I think many people are gonna
think that cow tattoo is the worst well
what are they saying in the comments why
don't we should Jack's pretty uh that's
pretty sympathetic to you those point of
view that's the line on the they're just
not to backup he'll I feel like well I
mean that you can disagree with me let's
throw the straw poll Dan I want to see
Ben Affleck cow hole and then Michael
Jackson yeah and there was a fourth
degree well those were the worst three
so let's throw those up and let's get a
straw poll going down on Twitter no one
and the Tropicana website mm-hmm Marilyn
Monroe is the other one yeah but I think
the met the Michael Jackson was even
worse than that but I feel like that one
that the two already's [ __ ] them up
like the merge Jackson one know them
Marilyn Monroe the person
yeah the Michael one looks like they did
it themselves almost you know it's on
their back but I feel like they did it
themselves
yeah we gotta get Ella doing more
segments I feel like this is fantastic
we've all been begging for ela Cline
movie reviews cuz she hates every movie
we got to do one for like end game
coming up that'll be fantastic but you
guys got to think like I said about the
whole package the tattoo guy is like
some some guy in in nowhere he looks
kind of old which kind of makes it
problem at the cow hole yeah the cook
the cow to to cow hole our pulls up in
the chat so you gotta really consider
like who is the person who made this ax
to what point in their life where they
at I put a lot of thought into it so
there's a lot of criteria that there's
the pole in the discord if you want
throw it up on screen votes are votes
are flowing in I'm voting for cow home
voting for cow whole personal cow whole
is taking an early leader capture yeah
well actually Ben Affleck is in third
you know I was thinking of the rip MJ I
was definitely thinking the rip MJ one I
think those two are worse actually agree
you guys also need to think think is so
rich you could get the beste to I was a
good tattoo it's
I thought I'd like the quality was good
the taste was bad wrong am I wrong okay
I mean what now do I know but now whole
definitely can't beat that eel I mean
come on I mean but you have some backers
it's not any of eighteen percent but I
don't think of anything I like that
there's a lot for it rip MJ because I
was considering that one myself yeah
there is something to be said about the
fact that he denied it like that somehow
does make it kind of funnier that is a
special for a movie
yeah which movie was that for Ben
Affleck then Penn Affleck myopic alright
congratulations everybody cow hole okay
and Ben Affleck and third but ela you've
got a strong opinions about what you
think I don't what everyone else thinks
doesn't matter guys dj khaled is back
and he's looking better than ever
the kick is back that was fun wasn't it
that was a good time I want to put you
to the test more focus Ethan one thing
you focus on that there's a new road
we're walking down I think I have ADHD
ADHD ADHD keep saying because I really
have a hard time focusing like when I'm
working at the deuteron I'm I cannot
focus they would it could edit like
three videos in the time yet it's one
and yeah he's still doing it fast but
every minute it will always haven't be
looking at some subreddit and then going
down some I forget what I'm doing topic
that it doesn't even know why he's
looking I'll go so deep and and I'll
forget what I'm what I'm doing I'll
forget where I am and like ten that's
like oh yeah I was looking for some
sound bite yeah look for a sound bite
like for the video and then I'll go so
down far a rabbit hole I'll forget what
why I'm not editing but I've tried like
adderall my dad takes adderall cuz
apparently he decided he has ADHD when
he was 65 I was like dude come on you
just like taking adderall but whatever
that's my
for you but I've tried taking adderall
in it and it really doesn't help I just
feel a crackdown maybe I took too much
because that's what you're supposed to
take when you have ADHD okay that's the
intended yes
yeah it's supposed to make you focus
yeah I just felt cracked out dude I
think I must have taken too much but
people who have ADHD take that every day
and I can't imagine like so for me it
was very intense drug thoughts I it's
funny I tried it and did the opposite to
me but I think it's because I don't need
it
opposite hell like I couldn't focus oh
you were scatterbrained yeah yeah I
think that's what they say if you don't
need it it doesn't help and if you do it
does yeah yeah my dad needs ADHD to
watch Game of Thrones I need to adderall
to watch Game of Thrones he goes I got
dad why you taking why are you taking a
header all he goes it helps me focus I'm
like dude you sit in front of TV all day
what do you need help focusing on you'll
do [ __ ] you're retired
have you tried operating that remote
yeah it can be stressful I have it's a
you need focus figure that out okay
where were we dj khaled is back the King
has returned
he is looking glorious foolish as ever
heavy lies the crown he posted this
video of he says this is my biggest
album I'm going all-out fan love
everything top secret father of Assad
May 17 so here I guess they're there
shooting some kind of music video in
front of a huge green screen you could
see that athleticism and the it's all
crying laughing emojis isn't that in the
comments yeah you can see that lettuce
is I'm here feast your eyes he's got a
crown and a sword he's fighting a huge
ogreish dude
and you can see how realistic this gets
[Music]
he doesn't even get anywhere near him
with the sword the director went a
little overkill but we'll get it he
thinks he killed it the director was
like a little overkill however you're
what dome oh okay but listen everybody
here let me turn the audio because you
can hear everyone's laughing at him I
[Music]
don't think I think there's supposed to
look badass not funny
I saw audio said yeah damn little
overkill but we'll get it and then he's
trying to give him directions he doesn't
listen he walks off starts talking to
Instagram can you imagine a director why
is the audio sound like Mars I don't
really know what you mean but you don't
hear like that you know it might have
been it might be a weird phasing thing
because there's audio from a cell phone
that happens sometimes so we're looking
forward to the king I can't wait great
this is great check that sounds right on
the stream and they're good I'm super
comp hopefully it's good we can make a
reaction videos how about how would that
be for a blast from the past series
because I feel like Khaled isn't as
popular as it used to be I mean this
video has a million views after four
days it needs to be king khalid the god
now he's out here getting a million
views in four days and this is good
content too
you know I mean let me see what else is
going on it's Instagram page
this one only has four thousand plays
that's not a lot eight minutes ago
thirteen thousand likes he's getting you
know what I mean
twenty-eight thousand likes 50,000 likes
32 thoughts so he's nobody he used to be
the king
I mean do you know what I'm saying like
[Music]
major king and major key so I'm doing
Saturday Night Live and I'm doing it
season finale
he needs to refresh the movies just
that's right repeating he's a meme
jukebox they said I'd never do Saturday
Night Live no they didn't who said that
nobody literally that's way too specific
Khalid nobody ever told you that it's an
ad by the way his announcements that
he's gonna be on Saturday Night Live
hasn't had it says hashtag ad official
Bellaire the champagne
man you gotta appreciate him he monetize
his everything guys don't be upset at my
live I'm super excited
shut up the bel-air their champagne is
great as a shower I don't taste it
how's it taste
I need to I need to monetize more I'm
not the one you know I mean I gotta
monetize more like like here why don't
we have a beverage sponsoring us I'm
drinking this Coke Zero getting they're
getting free ad you know huge bel air
champagne yeah Dan come on what are you
doing back there gave me some books I'm
water what is this getting the clown
branded
turn on the on the phone right now
another one come on shredder gotta put
some sponsors on shredder we showed a
picture of him I've been wearing like a
Petsmart hey he's looking at me he's so
smart shredder so smart it blows my mind
he understands everything
he really does the the morning we were
living to the make-a-wish meeting we
were I personally was nervous I think
you were too and we kind of woke up
early and we were like you know can't be
late so we were like all stressed
getting ready and shredder could sense
it and they puked from stress yeah he
puked twice he knows when we're leaving
without him he can tell by our routine
and so he gets all sheepish and like he
gets all sad and he just like watches
from the bed but then he can tell when
he's coming with us and he gets super
excited and prepped me and like so say
he won't even take treats when he said
yeah he's such a sweetheart yeah I'm
talking about you you know who I'm
talking about him all right well we're
reaching our an hour hour-and-a-half
mark so what do we got here we got shark
tank fill we got worst day on truck we
got little zan is a special needs child
and we've got Colonel Sanders DJ that
one's pretty good let's do em all we're
doing at all
it's Friday it's been a long week I'm
sure you guys all had a long week so
let's let's get some entertainment in
our world let's do them all okay but
from this point on I guarantee nothing
so this is the Wild West time so if
you're listening lower your expectations
because I guarantee nothing cuz they
were so high before yeah well at the
beginning I'm like hey thanks for
watching and now I'm just like said err
I'll stop that err ancestry.com new
cringy commercial what do you think
about this helo apparently they took it
down cuz it was so bad
ancestry.com Abigail we can escape to
the north there's a place we can be
together across the border
will you leave with me
without you the story stops here the
chapters of your family well why did
they have to make it about like slaves
well first of all it's so corny yeah and
second of all why did it have to be a
story of like a white man running off
with a slave and third of all the slave
didn't seem into it right she never said
yes she was never excited it seemed
almost like she was being coerced into
it yeah she had this look like dude I
don't trust this white man's got all the
power like you're shooting the
commercial at least put the make it seem
like she wants to go like watch this
again she's so not into it Abigail we
can escape to the north there's a place
we can be together she was about to be
like I don't even know you
she's like she didn't even say anything
I haven't no stay here right like she
yeah that's why I've been with you right
no yeah cuz right I have to right yeah
this is like some ancient and so that
she's in love with them will you leave
with me
not even a smile without you the story
stops here what does Ava mean I don't
know yeah
so they got slammed and they took it
down within hours
yeah they put a lot of work into that
but it's so poorly conceived I mean man
oh man
nobody along like no executive along the
way it was like this isn't a good idea
so that's pretty bad yeah
would you like to run away with me how
bad is it like cow it's a - is it yeah I
like that better
MJ Fant recipes MJ but it's pretty bad
yeah it's not as not as bad as cow hole
though I think that Cour tattoo is like
the ultimate dad joke yep take him way
too far oh it's awful yeah but every
time he takes his shirt off he just got
a huge smile on his face he loves the
attention and everyone freaking out
around him yeah yeah that's definitely
true and everyone's taking pictures and
he's just like loving it Ben Affleck on
the other hand he's gonna lie about it
you know what that's a that's a really
strong argument in favor of been in
favor of been vain warrants yes not
saying I agree early but it's a small
yeah I'll keep trying to convince him
it's a strong argument Shark Tank failed
we actually saw this live but I want to
watch it yeah yes these guys put ad or
presentation together I mean they were
watching you know we're big fans of
Shark Tank so we were watching live and
I couldn't believe what I was seeing man
when I watch this
the guys are demonstrating a new age
super strong lock that comes from a
bottom of the door and shoots up so that
you cannot open the door because it's
like sandwich through the bottom and so
they're like look how easy it is to bust
a regular traditional deadbolt yeah and
so let's see how you can you lock it
an experienced intruder can get in in
about five kicks Alex show them how easy
this is
come on now let's kick it hard come on
Alex
come on out give your heart five can't
do it Alex didn't actually end up
getting a deal but there's something
like super saying about this door cuz he
even things out like the crazy door bus
doesn't move I think the producers bust
with them right like the producers put
this together I feel like they must have
put some super [ __ ] in there but the
door buster doesn't the deadbolt are no
better Alex to the existing hold it
actually looks weaker than the wedge
base barrier lifts up using simple
physics this makes your entire door ten
times stronger - preventing home
break-in and tight port knock on the
gate to open the door to shut the door
you lock it with the gate with the foot
pedal and you can see what if you get
locked out with everything up
[Laughter]
[Music]
do the flank an experienced and shooter
will do a double jump flying jump
picking at your door there you have it
previously stuff here on Shark Tank
primetime baby and for those reasons I'm
out
that's right he actually got a deal
which shocked the hell out of me I think
but what the hell do I know because we
are at the back end of the show where
nothing matters and nobody should be
watching let me show you an example of
that one anyone laughing pretty quiet in
here somebody at homes laughing what do
we got here Shark Tank worst it this was
killing me I was I you know I hope I
thought I enjoyed as much the second
time you know did you watch the whole
thing no okay good so this guy is having
the worst day ever
he's a truck driver and he's fit
chronicling his misfortunes from the day
if it should have much room
[Music]
bro
I had a train track after a forklift got
stuck in the back of his car so here's a
picture it says it stopped so now it's
just stopped and though the street the
Train he stopped there
[Music]
now it's backing up what is he doing
[Music]
[Applause]
if anything up again
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
- just one dude [ __ ] with them what
is going on with that train though it's
some of the comments explained this
happens every once in a while that like
every time is before it's at a junction
and he's like letting off different cars
so it I mean in the middle of the night
though when you know when oh my god it's
like a long fun nobody knows what's
going on he's just blocking the street
for like hours oh my god
[Laughter]
fantastic um we're balloon we run along
little Zen made of looks minute look I
don't know anything about little damn I
know he's friends with a lot of
youtubers I
I don't know man I mean the guy looks
like look I don't know him but I mean if
he looks like he has a zero IQ and his
girlfriend I guess they made a video
together when he was high really high on
something I don't know what I probably
zanuck the dude literally has a goose
bump tattoo on under his eyelid so it
looks like his eyes using I mean it's
the worst thing I've ever seen and he
literally is like tattoo worse than
benevolence I tattoo is one of the worst
things I've ever seen
ela mauers he's accurate yeah bro look
at your face why are you touching your
tongue
I'm also won't why is one of your eyes
closed more than the other one of the
eyes without the leakage is closed more
I don't know why that is this guy is
barely sentient I feel like he's almost
a plant at this point a vegetable if you
could say one food I don't like
there's a lot of trouble identifying one
what's like a type of food food mistake
people don't like to eat that's a tough
that's a lot of food this is like speech
therapy after someone had a stroke you
know what I mean this is like one day
when like someone who was living in
captivity with aunt wild animals for 20
years trying to learn English for the
first time a specific food do I like
chicken dry they say you don't like
allocated dog
they're like arguing about it what do I
get when I order a burger like how could
this our little Sam
this little zan is proof that if you're
famous maybe I don't what do I know but
I mean how [ __ ] balls little zan and
you're more or less than ben affleck a
few of the [ __ ] blows enter Ben Affleck
who would you choose choose you have to
choose you marry one and [ __ ] one this
oh it would almost feel like a child
like a vet like you said like it's a
vegetable it's almost like pedophilia
yeah cuz he's like he's literally like
you got to talk to him like he's five
well I feel like a five-year-old's more
stimulated honestly than him which is
Ben then yeah
little Zen silos in space is like so
unsymmetrical why is one I like clothes
more dude what the hell that guy's face
is so jacked all the strappy toes and
all that [ __ ] you look Tomatoes yeah he
likes Tomatoes he doesn't know why
though do you remember when he got eaten
too many hot cheetos yeah I did read
that heaven but do you really think it
was that or was it drugged lated you
know what I mean I hits it's hard to say
like I believe that this guy ate too
many ideas in hospital is that ulcer
from it okay wrap it up she has to like
but I'm just shocked first of all that
she forced that she you know he they in
this state that he said that they did
this video and second of all that they
uploaded it cuz he looks like I mean is
it possible is his state right this is
how you get him it's a good point I
don't know much about him though can you
have a negative IQ EULA I think we I
think I think what a negative IQ means
is that you make everyone around you
more done it's like a black hole of
stupidity just sex that sucks everything
up gangster gangster good talk about
tomatoes all day so somebody had a
really funny comment they go if you play
it and one-and-a-half speed he actually
sounds normal so here I'm gonna I'm
gonna go to one and a half speed
so I'm fast-forwarding it now and he
sounds normal parent yeah I showed her
who are you about it yeah
she's super fast 14 sounds normal but
she really liked it and then whoa sounds
normal
the next morning I asked a to be my
girlfriend
I said intercourse it's PG he document
yeah there you go that's how we met um
she's not into it
that way she's just trying to control
the Beast right I can't believe how hard
this question was for ya like it's like
a circuit board it was like a computer
from like he's got one RAM in his brain
what don't you want to eat this
processor was vegan food he's just like
what's a yeah it's fantastic I have a
question out is little zan net worth
disappear so if this guy is that how
successfully is guess he is fairly
successful there you go kids dream you
can achieve anything even with a
negative 20 IQ I was I was a Instagram
page man you're not gonna believe
someone [ __ ] they started doing like
this hipster Colonel Sanders a CGI it's
not a real person like bro do you really
think this guy would be eating KFC it's
a fake person this is CGI and they
managed to generate in a computer the
douchiest looking person on earth wait
wait
KFC is doing an ad for dr. pepper what
the f you're a brand you can't do brands
with other Randall's other brands paid
partnership with dr. pepper hmm having
an ice-cold dr. pepper hashtag add your
king of Seger but what this is this is
you the collabing what what they said
that they were paid by dr. pepper
anyway I probably owned by the same
company I bet you well why would they
have to just yeah there's only like
three giant companies that own all the
fast food brands you want any cave so
today I got my brain dude oh my gosh I
want KFC you know but it might the funny
thing about this is look at this douche
this guy eats freakin this guy eats
Kanoa salads and super bowls only and
pokey when he's feeling wild yeah give
me a break
this guy doesn't put fried chicken in
his body they come up with yeah he's
such a douche why did you have to find
like the douchiest here he is with Jesse
wounds look at this Jesse did a
sponsored ad with him where they're
writing oh my god I just feel bad like
man I mean Jesus Christ I mean it scroll
down I just want you to scroll down I
want to see his shoes okay you've got to
take over because I'm office-wide shoes
think it I think he's a high breeze
let's do Sanders I hate to say it but I
feel like they modeled this off after
Jesse well bit well here yeah but his
whole thing dressed like Jesse I like
Jesse he's a great guy he's a sweet guy
he rides with two Sanders so he's good
in my book but I get to you how often
does Jesse eat KFC you know what I mean
less than me mm-hmm so where's my chubby
Sanders - trying to reach new new crowd
you know you want chubby guys like me
you know what really pissed me off
and again Harley from Epic Meal Time
friend of the show of the guy he
recently did on Instagram a freaking
Papa John's commercial and I'm so pissed
what I've been trying to get in touch
with Papa John dear here they are
missing an opportunity of a lifetime
they keep going up the shack they keep
going after Peyton Manning Oh Harley
because he's the food guy
why am I constantly snubbed and ignored
these marketers need to get their head
out of the house I will sell more
[ __ ] pizzas than all of them combined
right ela we already do people send us
pictures with buck with John boxes like
every day thank you he's always a Travis
private jet bro shut up more Dr Pepper
ads apparently Tom Green Oh just ran
into Tom Green whatever shut up colonel
he looked so faking this one look at his
face this is so weird
yeah I don't get it not into it but I do
like KFC please sponsor me do we have
the post of the Harley ad he made a
video for the Papa John can we get that
yeah one sec meanwhile I shall weep at
the bottom of this document
oh I do have it mm-hmm okay great Harley
Papa John had look at this [ __ ] you
believe this [ __ ] huge announcement as
the sauce boss I feel it is imperative
you hear the excellent news the sauce
boss I'm the Papa
sorry Papa's over sauce boss part of the
you knew I miss her Papa John you
couldn't have done this but they came
and the John's is turning up the heat
literally check this out what kind of
[ __ ] promo is that a free dipping
sauce yeah that's a dumbest don't you
get it anyway you get an extra one for
free
by Caesar I'm not but it slaps back for
sure
so if you like it and you enjoy it you
let Papa John's know you post a comment
in the comment section below and they'll
make this a regular staple ice for me
I'm gonna be dipping all night bro
that's the worst promo ever sorry Papa
John's talk to me talk to me we're gonna
do it I will singular ly raise their
stock value up to where it was when Papa
was in the house
Papa's out of the house I'm still
outside looking in am I wrong I mean
it's please what is going on here
why is hardly getting Papa John ads and
I am NOT talking about an extra free
sauce I almost feel like in a way though
it's kind of good that they've ignored
us cuz once you're actually paid for it
it's not the same yeah they would
probably been you end up making a post
like that it's not funny they would rein
me in big-time so Ethan we have a
promotion today we're giving away a free
sauce and we need you to be serious and
not funny about it okay so today is
extra sauce day so go ahead and announce
that it's extra sauce day today hey guys
it's Ethan this would be the final hey
guys it's Ethan
happy extra sauce day or like today we
are offering to bake the pie 5 degrees
higher than Donoho what a thrilling
adventure today today only guys you can
cook your pie for 5 minutes extra and
get an extra crispy only today remember
tell him Ethan sent you yeah they
probably they probably cut my balls
right off no no I'm not hitting on
Harley I just wish the Papa John would
record it is what I've done for him of
course I'm bitter about everything
nothing I say is personal everything I
say is personal towards me I'm the
bitter [ __ ] it's coming out of my
mouth thought there's judge me
everything I say is a reflection of my
own problem remember that we see the
world not as
it is but as we are okay and clearly you
know how I see it
so really yeah you get the idea here
boys let's go on down to fan submissions
hello there h3 podcast remember if you
want to submit a h3 podcast at a tree
directors calm did you catch that no and
you said it wrong it's podcast at e3
production in Stockholm thank you again
he says I'm not sure if there's a way to
do something like this but this video is
one of the greatest bits of
public-access television I've ever seen
and I feel like Ethan and ela would have
a field day with it it's like a Tim and
Eric sketch come on accident and never
gets old to me here's the link it's
called that's amore posted by Mark
Henson on YouTube thank you Jason for
the submission now actually Tim and Eric
I know they were their inspiration i
watch this video I was I was totally
blown away by like just how it formed
there
[Music]
it is barely moving in
it's Casey and his brother
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you've got that the worktop
[Music]
that's like two words
[Music]
yes congratulations then Wow of could
see back on the show
that was great fantastic excellent they
can submit romesco sauce
Ethan Hathaway writes us listening to
Gus Johnson podcast and y'all we're
talking about pizza I could not live
with myself I didn't tell you the best
pizza of all time
get ranch instead of pizza sauce bacon
and tomato that way the ranch cooks
makes it even better please try this
piece will change your life No so are
you saying instead of tomato sauce you
put ranch and then you cook it with the
ranch on it that's pretty gnarly dude
that is wack not good I'm and that comes
with a wrench
sounds like gross I can't I would try it
if it was presented to me but I wouldn't
I wouldn't go out of my way to make that
pie
that's definitely not a moria some stuff
you just don't want it you don't want it
to be a warm like ranch I don't see that
cooked ranch
it was just like curdled there's like
all that dairy in it right try it look
Ethan's pathway says it's bomb so who
are you to call him out what would you
say to ethan athlete for you he was here
right now that's this affirmation guys
isn't it Dan would spit in your face eat
then I don't have to check his tattoos I
have a feeling it's gonna weird and
wrench to two and finally as we come to
an end in France Papa John is still the
face of Papa John's viva la resistance
from Benjamin large hi there just a
quick mail to show you how France is
still fighting there's still only one
puppy here la resistance here you go
this is I guess from oh that gets from
Papa John there is your boy with the
dough enjoy John
not for long yeah they just haven't got
there yet they're gonna it's gonna be
Shaq soon that's so sad what happened no
iconic though you can't replace he's
such a pizza boy look at him what that
doe so happy to be there
what no no to play that one wait was
that the copyright one or that feeling
okay sorry sorry
alright hit me with that
my name is Papa John Shannon
viva la Revis resistance in France they
still my name here France but in America
that god bless him you were saying where
I was born and grew up they reject me
and my own capture my own people I said
how could you do this
and this pizza Empire I built with my
gay and now I am out best
I am left like a couple of pepperonis in
some heat you leave a couple of
pepperonis out in the summer heat you
cannot to use it of pepperoni on the pie
no more if that is how they have gots to
be assigned like a meat so with ranch
cooked into the crust
instead of sauce that is how I feel
today but in France viva la resistance
they know me
that's the Papa the one and only beat
semester and like the mozzarella Mets
Ponte cheese I shall melts as well into
a pizza grave and I say goodbye to this
world and just like when you have a
jalapeno on your pie and it's a little
too spicy and you end up having diarrhea
for days that is like USA had a diarrhea
me out I feel like pineapple nobody
likes it a pineapple on the pie huh only
Ethan and Ethan's the only one there
like me anymore
[Music]
happy Friday to everyone from the Papa
that is the end of the show and remember
viva la resistance outside looking in
goodbye this is good
[Music]